salut tout le monde
bonjour
est prêt puis quand le haché
e
[Musique]
les oignons poireaux parfait c'est top
salut Julien salut ça va ça va et toi
nickel bon je suis venu chercher les
poules de Houdan pour pouvoir faire la
poule au pot et puis j'aurais bien aimé
pouvoir faire un tour avec toi que tu
m'expliques un petit peu ta façon
d'élever les volailles
tu montrerais un petit peu les arrières
et j'aimerais bien comprendre un peu
plus on va aller voir ça
je vais te faire voir les reproducteurs
que j'ai ok
des poules ensemble qui me servent à
faire des œufs pour pouvoir produire des
poussins moi-même d'accord
j'ai un petit Châtel de reproducteur
qu'on a sélectionné surtout pour la pour
la masse d'accord alors on essaie de
bien garder les critères de beauté elles
sont belles
donc faut bien là houpette après faut
pas trop de noir pas trop de blanc alors
après les spécialistes connaissent mieux
que moi il y a un nombre de plumes à
respecter et tout mais moi je m'occupe
surtout du poids et de la chair tu peux
regarder elle est très lourde
bon alors après la dose en mais je
trouve que pour une ou deux ans c'est
très lourd
ça fait son poids j'ai une couveuse avec
des œufs en train de couver une couveuse
un éclosoir avec une éclosion en cours
et après j'ai des poussins en train de
démarrer
[Musique]
c'est bien de voir justement que il y a
des personnes comme toi qui travaillent
sur sur la continuité du d'une poule
comme la poule de Houdan qui est
aujourd'hui est difficile à élever
[Musique]
donc il y a quatre semaines ils étaient
comme les petits qu'on a vu dans la
couveuse
ils sont bons à consommer à partir de 5
mois et demi à peu près quoi là j'en ai
des Houdan là j'en ai 280 vous le faire
ça pour me démarquer un peu puis je me
disais tiens je suis dans le secteur de
Houdan je trouvais ça une bonne idée
Manu l'objectif du restaurant c'est la
même c'est faire en sorte que cette race
continue à vivre et essayer de la mettre
à l'honneur sur la table
[Musique]
bon je vais récupérer ma commande du
coup ouais bah bien elle est prête elle
est là et puis on va les cuisiner tout
ça
[Musique]